Das ist nicht echt.
Das ...
Bitte sag mir, dass das nicht echt ist.
Ich habe die Daten geprüft.
Ghostbusters, Star
Wars, Star Trek, Ocean’s Eight.
Dieser verdammte Wokeism ist dabei,
alles zu zerstören.
Frauenquote, Pay-Gap, MeToo.
Die wollen unsere Jobs,
die wollen unser Geld.
Und wenn wir nicht spuren, dann
canceln sie uns.
Wir müssen was tun, Ralf!
Frau Präsidentin!
Hier ist Professor Dr. Aurel Mertz von der MASA.
MASA,
Das ist kein Scherz.
Und jetzt?
Dann leaken wir die Wahrheit eben selbst.
Medien und Politik werden
von einer feministischen Elite kontrolliert.
Aber Frauen sind von Natur aus
trotzdem keine Führungsperson.
Sie wollen Männer weich machen
und Kinder schwul.
Wir Männer müssen uns wehren.
Lasst die Politiker wissen, dass sie
nicht länger untätig bleiben können.
Geht auf die Straße!
Die Regierung will uns zensieren.
Ihre Internet-Bewegung behauptet,
dass Männer nichts mehr sagen dürfen.
Aber dann wären Sie ja
wohl kaum hier, oder?
Wir werden täglich angefeindet,
nur weil wir anderer Meinung sind.
Wenn wir zum Beispiel sagen,
dass Gleichberechtigung unnatürlich ist,
dann bekommen wir kritische
Nachrichten geschickt
in All Caps.
Die machen unsere Sprache kaputt,
unsere Kultur.
Die bringen uns dazu, im Geschichtsunterricht ein schlechtes Gewissen zu haben.
Ich frage dich:
Wann hört diese Tyrannei endlich auf?
Das ist nicht witzig.
Männlichkeit droht auszusterben.
Männer werden überall unterdrückt.
Wo genau? Zum Beispiel Gefängnisse.
Die sind voller Männer.
Warum kommen nicht mal Frauen in den Knast?
Weil sie viel weniger Straftaten begehen.
Sie sind jemand,
mit dem kann man nicht reden.
Mit dem kann man nicht reden!
Die Umfragewerte der Präsidentin
waren zuletzt besonders unter Männern
stark gesunken.
USA: Die NASA gibt noch keine Entwarnung.
Der Komet könnte laut Experten doch
gefährlich nah an die Erde kommen.
Stay strong, stay Alpha!
Und kaufen Sie meinen Alpha-Merch,
ich hab’ 10.000 Shirts zu viel bestellt.
Herr Mertz? Professor Dr. Mertz,
hier spricht die Präsidentin.
Ich glaube,
wir hatten einen schlechten Start.
Ich möchte Ihnen gerne ein Angebot machen.
Nach einer erfolgreichen
Wiederwahl hat die Regierung schärfere
Abtreibungsgesetze verabschiedet.
Männerrechtler auf der ganzen Welt
atmen auf.
Das Leiden hat ein Ende.
Das macht doch überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Was für ein Leiden?
Das ist Täter-Opfer-Umkehr.
So eine kranke Scheiße!